This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Every year park rangers and trail workers across the US take part in a kind of scavenger hunt on their days off. They're looking for a particular tool, one that's often over 100 years old, but to them it shines like a diamond. And with the right combination of strategy and luck, they might spot the perfect one, on the wall of a local cracker barrel restaurant. That's 99PI producer, Lashemadon. Because this hot commodity is an antique, steel blade, cross cut saw. Imagine one of those old, timey lumberjack photos. The kind where two men in plaid are working away at a tree, holding opposite ends of a huge human-length saw.
这里是《99%无形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。每年，全美的公园管理员和步道工作人员都会在休息日参加一种寻宝游戏。他们寻找的是一种特殊的工具，这种工具通常有100多年的历史，但在他们眼中，它就像钻石一样闪闪发光。如果策略和运气结合得当，他们可能会在当地一家Cracker Barrel餐厅的墙上发现完美的藏品。这就是《99PI》的制作人拉什马·多恩。因为这种抢手货是一把古董钢刃横切锯。想象一下那些老式的伐木工照片。那种两个穿着格子衬衫的男人在树旁忙碌，手里拿着一把巨大的、人那么长的锯子两端。
That is a vintage cross cut. Oh gosh. The first saw I named, I named all with a king Arthur theme. So I had Arthur and Gwynnevere, of course, and then along came Lance a lot. This is Dolly Chapman. She's worked on trail crews for more than three decades, building and maintaining trails with the U.S. Forest Service.
那是一把老式横切锯。天哪。我命名的第一把锯子，我用亚瑟王的主题给它们命名。所以我有了亚瑟和格尼薇儿，当然，后来又有了兰斯洛特。这是多莉·查普曼。她在步道工作组工作了三十多年，与美国林务局一起修建和维护步道。
And Garif and Lynette, who were a couple, and Elaine, and Percival. And of course, I have ex-caliber as my favorite acts. Dallies and expert at finding, using, and maintaining these coveted sauce. And she's got a matchmaking reputation. People call her up to get paired with their perfect cross cut. Dallies saws hang side-by-side in her workshop in Northern California, looking a little bit like a walk-in closet full of incredibly sharp clothes. She has 40 of these vintage saws in her collection, which is pretty amazing,
还有加里夫和琳内特，他们是一对情侣，还有伊莱恩和珀西瓦尔。当然，我最喜欢的锯子是“断钢剑”。多莉是寻找、使用和维护这些令人垂涎的锯子的专家。她还有“红娘”的美誉。人们打电话给她，希望能为他们配上一把完美的横切锯。多莉的锯子并排挂在她北加州的作坊里，看起来有点像一个装满了极其锋利衣服的步入式衣橱。她的收藏中有40把这样的老式锯子，这非常了不起，
given the links that soiers and collectors go to in order to get their hands on even one of these things. A lot of what I like about them is there's so much more to them than you see at first glance. I saw it for Ezure when the previous owner saw junk. Some people spend hours mining websites like eBay and Craigslist, other search in person on saw hunting road trips, driving up and down highways to stop by yard sales, antique stores, and even places where the saws
考虑到锯工和收藏家为了得到其中一把所付出的努力。我喜欢它们的原因很大程度上是因为它们远比第一眼看上去的要丰富得多。当原主人把它看作垃圾时，我却把它视为珍宝。有些人花几个小时在eBay和Craigslist等网站上挖掘，另一些人则亲自开车去进行“寻锯之旅”，沿着高速公路行驶，顺便去逛庭院旧货甩卖、古董店，甚至去那些锯子
aren't technically for sale. If you go in restaurants in rural areas, restaurants and bars, you see painted saws hanging above the bar and on the wall. I'm sure you've been in a restaurant with a painted saw on the wall and not noticed it yet. On its face, it may seem a little intense, you know, to care about old saws so much that you end up trying to barter with your cracker barrel server because they have a wall decoration, you just really want to take home.
技术上并不出售的地方。如果你走进农村地区的餐馆、酒吧，你会看到漆过的锯子挂在吧台上方和墙上。我相信你一定去过那种墙上挂着漆过锯子的餐馆，只是还没注意到而已。表面上看，为了几把旧锯子而如此执着，甚至试图与Cracker Barrel的服务员讨价还价，只因为墙上的装饰品是你真的很想带回家的东西，这似乎有点过火了。
But the vintage crosscuts that trail crew leaders go hunting for. They aren't just for show. Often, the plan is to put these saws back to use. After the paint has been scrubbed clean and the teeth have been sharpened, many return to the woods, bucking and felling trees in the American outdoors. In fact, vintage crosscuts that were made between 1880 and 1930 are often the tool of choice for the hundreds of trail workers who maintained the American backcountry today. That's head of chain saws and newly made crosscuts.
但步道工作组组长们寻找的老式横切锯不仅仅是为了展示。通常，计划是让这些锯子重新投入使用。在刷掉油漆并磨利锯齿后，许多锯子回到了森林中，在美国的户外砍伐树木。事实上，1880年至1930年间制造的老式横切锯，往往是今天维护美国偏远地区步道的数百名工作人员的首选工具。这比链锯和新制造的横切锯更受欢迎。
And the reason this old tool has stuck around for so long, even in an age where there's a newer, better gadget coming out every year, it goes way beyond the physical saw itself. Because the rise, fall, and unexpected second life of the Crosscut saw is the story of how America created the very concept of wilderness. Wilderness. It's a word that summons images of old growth forests and ancient untouched mountain peaks. Honestly, when I hear that word and I think about it, I picture myself on a ridge in the mountains, looking probably across other ridges in the mountains.
这种古老工具之所以能存在这么久，即使在每年都有更新、更好的小玩意儿问世的时代，其原因也远不止锯子本身。因为横切锯的兴起、衰落和意想不到的“第二人生”，讲述了美国是如何创造出“荒野”这一概念的。荒野。这个词让人联想到原始森林和古老未受触动的山峰。老实说，当我听到这个词并思考它时，我脑海中浮现出自己站在山脊上，俯瞰着远处其他山脊的画面。
This is Adam Soards. I'm an environmental historian and have studied public lands for about a quarter of a century, national parks, national forests, things like that. The concept of wilderness might seem like it's been around forever, like it came with the planet as a kind of package deal. But in the long history of the natural world, the idea of wilderness that we're familiar with today is actually pretty new. The word wilderness first popped into use in the year 1200, essentially to describe land not being used for farming.
这是亚当·索尔兹。我是一名环境历史学家，研究公共土地大约四分之一个世纪了，包括国家公园、国家森林等等。荒野的概念似乎一直存在，就像它是地球自带的“套餐”一样。但在自然世界的漫长历史中，我们今天所熟悉的荒野概念其实相当新。荒野这个词最早出现在1200年，本质上是用来描述未用于耕种的土地。
Much later, the colonization of North America gave wilderness a new meaning and a new purpose. It became a way to define and distinguish white settler society. Early wilderness in the US mostly meant danger, a place to be wary of. This kind of thinking helped European settlers define themselves in opposition to indigenous people. So starting around the 17th century, the idea was that white people lived in civilization, and indigenous people lived in the hostile wilderness. And for 200 years, that's how it went.
很久以后，北美殖民化赋予了荒野新的含义和目的。它成为定义和区分白人定居者社会的一种方式。早期的荒野在美国主要意味着危险，一个需要警惕的地方。这种思维方式帮助欧洲定居者将自己定义为原住民的对立面。因此，从17世纪左右开始，人们认为白人生活在文明中，而原住民生活在充满敌意的荒野中。两百年来，情况一直如此。
Wilderness didn't have the greatest reviews. Then came the Industrial Revolution, which was when wilderness started to take a different shape. Industrialization created the conditions for certain things to grow chaoticly and exponentially. Things like cities, factories, pollution, a working class. It shattered the old patterns of rural life and it brought on new ways of relating to land. There's a lot more people that are talking about the busyness of cities and the crowdedness of cities.
荒野的评价并不高。后来工业革命来了，荒野开始呈现出不同的形态。工业化创造了某些事物混乱且呈指数级增长的条件。比如城市、工厂、污染、工人阶级。它打破了旧有的农村生活模式，带来了与土地相关联的新方式。有更多的人在谈论城市的繁忙和拥挤。
The Crosscut Saw played a major part in America's industrialization. This tool, it helped Lager's topple countless Douglas Furs and Redwoods to make way for new cities. And Adam says that it was around this time during the chaos of the industrial revolution that wilderness had a glow up. So beginning in the mid-part, or the late part of the industrial revolution that wilderness had a glow up. So beginning in the mid-part, or the late part of the 19th century,
横切锯在美国的工业化进程中发挥了重要作用。这种工具帮助伐木工推倒了无数花旗松和红杉，为新城市腾出空间。亚当说，正是在工业革命的混乱时期，荒野经历了一次“华丽转身”。所以从工业革命的中后期，也就是19世纪末开始，
celebration of the wild begins. As steam and coal power came on the scene, cities got bigger, noisier, and more polluted. The idea of wilderness became more and more appealing as a contrast to the pressures of industrial capitalism. And as that industrialization expands and as the cities get bigger, that desire to not only have access to those places, but to create those places and protect them intensify.
对荒野的赞美开始了。随着蒸汽和煤炭动力的出现，城市变得更大、更吵、污染更严重。荒野的概念作为工业资本主义压力的对比，变得越来越有吸引力。随着工业化的扩张和城市的扩大，人们不仅想要进入这些地方，而且想要创造和保护这些地方的愿望也随之增强。
Wilderness started to represent an escape from an urban life that felt like it was expanding out of control. Writers and poets described wild spaces as pure instead of scary, safe instead of savage, no longer an un-farmed wasteland, but more of a temple, something of value to humans that needed to be protected from humans. There's sort of a religious dimension to part of that. There's an anti-urban dimension and an anti-urbanite position too.
荒野开始代表一种对城市生活的逃避，这种生活让人感觉正在失控地扩张。作家和诗人们将荒野描述为纯洁而非可怕，安全而非野蛮，不再是未耕种的荒地，而更像是一座神庙，一种对人类有价值、需要从人类手中保护的东西。这其中有一种宗教维度。还有一种反城市维度和反城市居民的立场。
So we don't like the people who live there, so we need to go to these other places where they might be pure. By the romantic era, American writers like Ralph Waldo Emerson and Henry David Throbe believed that wilderness was a creation of God that provided important space for intellectual and spiritual stimulation. A place where good men could become great men. The famous photographer, Ansel Adams, became known for his landscape photos of the American West.
所以我们不喜欢住在那里的人，所以我们需要去这些可能纯洁的地方。到了浪漫主义时期，拉尔夫·沃尔多·爱默生和亨利·戴维·梭罗等美国作家认为，荒野是上帝的创造，为智力和精神的激发提供了重要的空间。一个好人可以成为伟人的地方。著名摄影师安塞尔·亚当斯以其美国西部的风景照片而闻名。
And Adams helped propel the idea that America's wilderness was a point of pride and national identity. And maybe a lot of this kind of thinking is sounding familiar at this point. But at the time, the idea of wilderness was still mostly an intellectual and artistic one. Actual wild places weren't so accessible to the urban masses yet, and most people definitely weren't going there on vacation. That started to change in the early 1900s when the U.S. government established the
亚当斯帮助推动了这样一种观念：美国的荒野是自豪感和民族认同的源泉。也许这种想法在今天听起来很熟悉。但在当时，荒野的概念主要还是知识分子和艺术家的。真正的荒野对城市大众来说还不太容易到达，大多数人肯定不会去那里度假。这种情况在20世纪初开始改变，当时美国政府建立了
Forest Service and Park Service, and America's wild spaces started to gain national attention. You and your family can enjoy this wonderland at very modest rates because a variety of tent accommodations are available. Attent like this, with comfortable furnishings, lights, bedding, costs only $2.50 daily per person, and fine meals are available at least. An outdoor recreation movement took off that would only grow and grow and grow,
林务局和公园管理局，美国的荒野空间开始受到全国关注。您和您的家人可以以非常适中的价格享受这片仙境，因为有各种帐篷住宿可供选择。像这样的帐篷，配有舒适的家具、灯具、床上用品，每人每天只需2.50美元，而且可以享用精美的餐点。一场户外休闲运动兴起了，并且只会不断壮大，
as Americans hiked, canoeed, and camped their way into the first decades of the 20th century. Wilderness became a place where not just wealthy artists, but everyday Americans could find the promise of health, relaxation, and moral regeneration. By the 1920s, the park service was building cushy resorts, complete with dude ranches and even scheduled bear feedings. So in order to get as many tourists as possible into these parks, the government went hard on building roads. And all this development meant that the crosscut saw was an extremely high demand.
随着美国人在20世纪的前几十年里徒步、划独木舟和露营。荒野不仅成为富有的艺术家，也成为普通美国人寻找健康、放松和道德重塑希望的地方。到了20世纪20年代，公园管理局开始建造舒适的度假村，配有牛仔牧场，甚至还有定期的喂熊活动。因此，为了让尽可能多的游客进入这些公园，政府大力修建道路。所有这些开发意味着横切锯的需求量极大。
These saws were being churned out in huge numbers by manufacturers who were selling newer models every year. There were three main companies in the US that made them. There was the Distance Saw Company, the Atkins saw company, and the Simon's saw and steel company. They tried to outsell each other every year. They each made their own steel. By the Great Depression, millions of Americans were put to work.
这些锯子由制造商大量生产，他们每年都在销售更新的型号。美国有三家主要公司生产它们。分别是迪斯顿锯业公司、阿特金斯锯业公司和西蒙斯锯钢公司。他们每年都试图在销量上超过对方。他们各自制造自己的钢材。到了大萧条时期，数百万美国人投入工作。
Many of them wielding the crosscut to clear trails and lay down miles and miles of pavement. These saws helped make way for the next big thing that shaped wilderness history. Cars By this time, over a million cars were being sold in the country each year. Many of their owners eager to drive the widely publicized Park to Park Highway, which connected 13 national parks by road. From Yellowstone, you could drive north to Glacier, west to the Cascades, south through the Sierras, and east past the Grand Canyon.
他们中的许多人挥舞着横切锯清理步道，铺设了数英里的路面。这些锯子为塑造荒野历史的下一个重大事物铺平了道路：汽车。到那时，全国每年销售超过一百万辆汽车。许多车主渴望驾驶广受宣传的“公园到公园公路”，这条公路通过道路连接了13个国家公园。从黄石公园出发，你可以向北开车到冰川公园，向西到喀斯喀特山脉，向南穿过内华达山脉，向东经过大峡谷。
Travel and east, travel and west, wherever you go, Chevy services, Ben, Southwood or North, gear plates or far-dares, a Chevrolet team,, even for your Chevrolet car. See the U.S. thing in your Chevrolet. These new highways combined with affordable cars and promotional campaigns, well, they got millions of Americans outside. Within just four years, National Park Attendance tripled. But the success of these efforts concerned some of those early worshipers of the wild. With all these roads and tourism, it seemed to them that wilderness was at risk of losing its moral character, its purity.
无论你去哪里，雪佛兰服务，无论向南还是向北，无论齿轮还是远方，雪佛兰团队，甚至是你的雪佛兰汽车。驾驶你的雪佛兰看美国。这些新公路加上经济实惠的汽车和宣传活动，让数百万美国人走到了户外。仅仅四年内，国家公园的游客人数就增加了两倍。但这些努力的成功引起了一些早期荒野崇拜者的担忧。随着所有这些道路和旅游业的发展，在他们看来，荒野正面临失去其道德特征和纯洁性的风险。
The unique quality of wilderness was that it existed outside of human life. So if all these pristine landscapes would one day be rolled over by hundreds of cars a day, was that wilderness at all? of cars a day. Was that wilderness at all? And so in 1935, a new political movement started to emerge, spearheaded by a small group of people with one specific goal in mind. Let's not have roads everywhere. Let's keep some cars away. A group of eight Americans got together to defend the wilderness against recreational and commercial overuse. to defend the wilderness against recreational and commercial overuse. Among them was ecologist Alda Leopold
荒野的独特之处在于它存在于人类生活之外。那么，如果所有这些原始景观有一天被每天数百辆汽车碾过，那还是荒野吗？因此，在1935年，一场新的政治运动开始兴起，由一小群人领导，他们心中有一个特定的目标：不要到处修路。让我们让一些汽车远离。八名美国人聚在一起，保护荒野免受娱乐和商业的过度使用。其中包括生态学家奥尔多·利奥波德，
for a service chief Bob Marshall and Benton Mackay, the guy behind the Appalachian Trail. Together, they called themselves the wilderness society, and they had one specific enemy, the car. What united them was not every last detail about what they thought wilderness should be, but what united them was the every last detail about what they thought wilderness should be, but what united them was the fight against the automobile. The Wilderness Society wanted Congress to create a new type of federal land called Wilderness
林务局局长鲍勃·马歇尔和阿巴拉契亚步道的幕后推手本顿·麦凯。他们自称为“荒野协会”，他们有一个共同的敌人：汽车。团结他们的不是关于荒野应该是什么样子的每一个细节，而是反对汽车的斗争。荒野协会希望国会建立一种新的联邦土地类型，称为“荒野”，
with a capital W. They wanted wilderness to be part of the country's public lands, but unlike other types of public land, like national parks, forests, and monuments, wilderness would be a separate category, a place with specific and permanent restrictions on human activity. The wilderness society dreamed of preserving plots of land throughout the country,
大写的W。他们希望荒野成为国家公共土地的一部分，但与其他类型的公共土地（如国家公园、森林和纪念地）不同，荒野将是一个独立的类别，一个对人类活动有具体且永久限制的地方。荒野协会梦想着在全国范围内保护土地，
where roads and most types of commercial development would be forbidden. This included things like logging, resorts, or any type of human-made structure. This was a hard sell. I mean, setting aside millions of acres of land that you can't claim ownership of or make profit on doesn't sound very American to me. But they kept trying. As World War II swung around, wood became a critical war material, and the demand for
在那里禁止道路和大多数类型的商业开发。这包括伐木、度假村或任何类型的人造建筑。这很难推销。我的意思是，划出数百万英亩你不能拥有所有权或从中获利的土地，这对我来说听起来不太像美国作风。但他们一直在努力。随着第二次世界大战的到来，木材成为关键的战争物资，对
lumber grew exponentially. And it was around this time that chainsaws entered the chat. Within just a few years, chainsaws were doing all the work, and crosscut saws were completely obsolete. The efficiency of chainsaws helped fulfill the country's appetite for wood during the war. And because it could cut more wood at a faster rate, it had major economic appeal. Chain Saws so dramatically replaced the old crosscuts that crosscut manufacturing came
木材的需求呈指数级增长。正是在这个时候，链锯登场了。仅仅几年内，链锯就完成了所有的工作，横切锯完全过时了。链锯的效率帮助满足了国家在战争期间对木材的渴望。而且因为它能以更快的速度切割更多的木材，它具有巨大的经济吸引力。链锯如此戏剧性地取代了旧的横切锯，以至于横切锯的制造
to a grinding halt. So there were thousands of crosscut saws in the country belonging to logging companies, belonging to woodcutters, belonging to individuals for which there was no use anymore. Picture hundreds of crates of crosscut saws being pushed to the back of warehouses because no one wanted them anymore. These tools eventually found their way to antique stores or someone's basement. Others found new purpose as wall decoration. And just like that, with cross cuts no longer in use commercially at least, the American outdoors got a whole lot louder. Eventually, the wilderness society's anti-car campaign succeeded.
陷入了停滞。所以全国有成千上万把横切锯属于伐木公司、伐木工、个人，它们再也没有用处了。想象一下，成百上千箱横切锯被推到仓库后面，因为没人再想要它们了。这些工具最终流向了古董店或某人的地下室。另一些则作为墙面装饰找到了新的用途。就这样，随着横切锯至少在商业上不再使用，美国户外变得吵闹多了。最终，荒野协会的反汽车运动取得了成功。
After 66 legislative rewrites, wilderness became a concept that was signed into law. Members of the Cabinet and the Congress, ladies and gentlemen, this is very happy and historic occasion for all who love the great American outdoors. In 1964, Congress passed the Wilderness Act, and America did something no other country had ever done. It passed a law to protect land and preserve it in its natural state. The Wilderness Bill preserves our posterity for all time to come, 9 million acres of this vast continent in their original and unchanging beauty and wonder. It presented something powerfully new in public land's history by placing value on collective
经过66次立法重写，荒野成为一个被签署为法律的概念。内阁成员和国会议员，女士们，先生们，对于所有热爱美国伟大户外活动的人来说，这是一个非常快乐和历史性的时刻。1964年，国会通过了《荒野法案》，美国做了一件其他国家从未做过的事情。它通过了一项法律来保护土地并将其保持在自然状态。荒野法案为我们的后代永久保留了这片广阔大陆上900万英亩土地，使其保持原始、不变的美丽和奇迹。它通过将价值置于集体
restraint. Today there are roughly 112 million acres of protected wilderness. Wilderness went from being a set of cultural values to physical plots of land with defined borders and a legal definition. And not definition? Well, it's a doozy. Well, I have it right next to me. I can read off some of the phrases, in an area where the earth and its community of life are untrammeled by man, where man himself is a visitor who does not remain. Untrammeled. It's oddly poetic, a choice of word that somehow manages to be specific and a bit vague all at once.
克制之上，在公共土地历史上呈现出一种强大的新事物。今天，大约有1.12亿英亩的受保护荒野。荒野从一套文化价值观变成了具有明确边界和法律定义的物理土地。那个定义？嗯，它很特别。我就在旁边。我可以读出一些短语：“在地球及其生命共同体不受人类束缚的地区，人类本身只是一个不留下的访客。”不受束缚。这有一种奇怪的诗意，这种措辞选择不知何故既具体又有点模糊。
Wilderness is a place of primeval character that act goes on to say, that it should be preserved in its natural conditions and allowed to maintain its ecological freedom. One important thing to note about this new capital W wilderness is that the untrammeled part was actually enforceable by law, which meant that all this land suddenly had to be free of all mechanization and motors. There's a particular section of the act, section 4c if you want to follow along at home, and it excludes the use of motorized equipment, which means no snowmobiles, no jackhammers, no powered rock drills, and no chain saws, meaning that people working in the wilderness started to rely heavily on crosscut saws again. As in, sorry, Cracker Barrel, but we're going to need those crosscuts back.
荒野是一个具有原始特征的地方，法案接着说，它应该在自然条件下得到保护，并允许保持其生态自由。关于这个大写W的荒野，有一点很重要，那就是“不受束缚”的部分实际上是法律强制执行的，这意味着所有这些土地突然必须摆脱所有的机械化和动力设备。法案中有一个特定的部分，如果你想在家跟着看的话是第4c节，它排除了动力设备的使用，这意味着没有雪地摩托、没有手提钻、没有动力岩石钻，也没有链锯，这意味着在荒野工作的人开始再次严重依赖横切锯。也就是说，抱歉，Cracker Barrel，但我们需要把那些横切锯拿回来。
So, a saw. Now, there are all different types of saws. And I'm going to go over a bunch of them because it is fascinating. What I like about crosscuts is that I follow Dolly Chapman down to a national forest just outside San Diego, where she was leading a cross-cut saw training for park rangers and trail workers. At the end of the training, participants would walk away with a certification, allowing them to use cross-cuts on the job.
所以，锯子。现在，有各种各样的锯子。我要讲讲其中的很多种，因为这太迷人了。我喜欢横切锯的原因是，我跟随多莉·查普曼来到圣地亚哥郊外的一片国家森林，她在那里为公园管理员和步道工作人员进行横切锯培训。培训结束时，参与者将获得证书，允许他们在工作中操作横切锯。
I think we're ready for you guys to start grabbing saws and working together. This is the part of the day I wait before. Dali told me that when the Wilderness Act first passed, a lot of people didn't want to switch from chain saws to cross cuts. I worked on one national forest where instead of sawing fallen trees, they would blast them out of the way. And I was a blaster too and that sounded like fun. As in using explosives to clear trees instead of sawing them at all. And then there were the people who tried to sneak chainsaws in. But after a while, there were enough of a sharpening crosscuts and doing a really good job with it that people were saying, hey, this is fun. We want to use the crosscut saw.
我想我们准备好让你们开始拿锯子一起工作了。这是我一天中等待的时刻。多莉告诉我，当《荒野法案》刚通过时，很多人不想从链锯换成横切锯。我在一个国家森林工作，那里的人不是锯倒下的树，而是用炸药把它们炸开。我也是个爆破手，那听起来很有趣。也就是说，使用炸药清理树木，而不是锯掉它们。然后还有一些人试图偷偷带入链锯。但过了一段时间，有足够多的人磨利横切锯并做得非常好，以至于人们开始说，嘿，这很有趣。我们想用横切锯。
Now there are some case-by-case exceptions to the axe rule against motorized tools. But by drastically reducing the use of things like chainsaws, it's made wilderness areas quiet in a way that's unlike anywhere else. Quiet from all the human-made noise at least. Except when you're out there, it's actually loud. You can hear the wind, you can hear the water, you know, stumbling over the rocks. You hear the breeze through the trees, so you can hear all these things that you can't hear elsewhere when you're hearing traffic.
现在，对于禁止动力工具的法案规则，有一些个案例外。但通过大幅减少链锯等工具的使用，它使荒野地区变得安静，这与任何其他地方都不同。至少没有了所有人造噪音。除非你在那里，其实它很吵。你可以听到风声，你可以听到水声，你知道，在岩石上跌跌撞撞。你可以听到树林里的微风，所以你可以听到在其他地方听不到的所有这些声音，当你听到交通噪音时。
It's a strong, strong, strong, strong, strong. Crosscuts first made it come back because they had to, but now they're increasingly desirable, even in non-wilderness areas, where chain saws are technically allowed. With a lot of forested land seeing increasingly long fire seasons, some trail crews are finding that crosscuts are just safer. You don't need to haul a bunch of flammable fuel like you would with a chainsaw.
这是一种强大、强大、强大、强大、强大的力量。横切锯之所以能回归，是因为它们必须回归，但现在它们越来越受欢迎，即使在技术上允许使用链锯的非荒野地区也是如此。随着许多林地经历越来越长的火灾季节，一些步道工作组发现横切锯更安全。你不需要像使用链锯那样携带大量易燃燃料。
And the relative quiet of a crosscut is a lot less disturbing to wildlife. Ever since the crosscut revival though, the vintage saw has become harder to find, especially as some are being snatched up by collectors or competitive lumberjacks. Many others are being kept as family heirlooms. In fact, the wilderness act and its emphasis on the purity of nature. It's kindled interest from a whole subculture of diehard crosscut users, sharpeners, and collectors. Back at Dolly's training, people continued taking turns pulling a cross cut through a fallen log, 2x2.
而且横切锯的相对安静对野生动物的干扰要小得多。不过，自从横切锯复兴以来，老式锯子变得更难找到了，尤其是因为一些被收藏家或竞技伐木工抢购一空。许多其他的则被当作传家宝保存。事实上，《荒野法案》及其对自然纯洁性的强调，激发了整个死忠横切锯用户、磨锯人和收藏家亚文化的兴趣。回到多莉的培训现场，人们继续轮流拉着横切锯穿过一根倒下的原木，二对二。
Pretty soon, it was my turn. And as I hesitantly walked towards the log, I thought back to a moment that morning when everyone shared what they loved about this tool. A well-sharp and vintage cross cut moves cleanly across the grain of a log, pulling out wood in a sort of noodle-like shape. Dolly says the test of a good saw is if you see a pile of fresh spaghetti forming at your feet as you move back and forth. And then when you're sawing through wood with it, it makes a singing noise, just a beautiful, comfortable, rhythmic sort of... I won't say it sounds like bells, but it's kind of a singing noise. And, sure, you're sweating in your goggles and your hard hat, butt muscles clenched in preparation for every pull. But there's also something elegant about it. This saw demands a kind of dance between two people,
很快，轮到我了。当我犹豫着走向原木时，我想起了那天早上每个人分享他们喜欢这个工具的原因。一把磨得很好的老式横切锯可以干净利落地切开原木的纹理，拉出一种面条状的木屑。多莉说，好锯子的测试标准是，当你来回拉动时，你会看到一堆新鲜的“意大利面”在你脚下形成。当你用它锯木头时，它会发出一种歌唱般的声音，一种美丽、舒适、有节奏的声音……我不会说它听起来像铃铛，但它是一种歌唱般的声音。当然，你戴着护目镜和安全帽，汗流浃背，臀部肌肉紧绷，为每一次拉动做准备。但它也有优雅的一面。这把锯子需要两个人之间的一种舞蹈，
a thoughtful exercise in communication and trust. In short, what people tend to love most about the crosscut is in the experience. These days, new crosscut saws are being manufactured again. There are modern-day crosscuts available for purchase online. And Dali says there's actually plenty of these models lying around mostly unused in federal storage facilities. When the US government spends money on tools, there are a lot of requirements that they buy only new equipment and that they
一种关于沟通和信任的深思熟虑的练习。简而言之，人们往往最喜欢横切锯的是那种体验。如今，新的横切锯又开始制造了。网上有现代横切锯可供购买。多莉说，实际上联邦存储设施里有很多这种型号的锯子闲置着。当美国政府在工具上花钱时，有很多要求，比如他们只能购买新设备，而且他们
buy American-made equipment. And we really don't want our government employees to be buying things off of eBay or buying antiques that doesn't sound professional. So no need to dig around for secondhand tools in old logging towns. And yet every trail worker I've spoken to for this story has said they strongly prefer the vintage crosscut. Even the Forest Service published a study in 2005 comparing the quality of vintage and modern saws, favoring the older ones.
购买美国制造的设备。我们真的不希望我们的政府雇员从eBay上买东西或购买古董，那听起来不专业。所以没必要在旧伐木小镇挖掘二手工具。然而，我为这个故事采访过的每一位步道工作人员都表示，他们强烈偏爱老式横切锯。甚至林务局在2005年也发表了一项研究，比较了老式和现代锯子的质量，更倾向于旧的。
These are just better, and a lot of us, I'd say, me included, would only want to use an antique saw because it is better. It's going to feel better in the hand, better balance, better flex to the metal. It'll stay sharp longer, it'll cut smoother. They're just far superior to anything made today. These old saws, they're made from a higher quality steel and the teeth are set in a crescent-shaped arc. So there are practical arguments that they do cut better. But perhaps more important is something less tangible than the shape of the arc and the quality of the steel.
这些就是更好，我们中的许多人，包括我在内，只会想用古董锯，因为它更好。它在手中感觉更好，平衡感更好，金属的弹性更好。它能保持锋利的时间更长，切割更平滑。它们远优于今天制造的任何东西。这些旧锯子是用更高质量的钢材制成的，锯齿呈新月形排列。所以有实际的论点认为它们确实切得更好。但也许更重要的是一些比弧形和钢材质量更无形的东西。
I think more and more. I like this one because it has a history because it might have worked in a logging camp because it's 90 years old because I restored it from real wreckage on the back floor of an antique store. So there is that nostalgia. That nostalgia for the antique crosscut,
我想越来越多的人喜欢这一把，因为它有历史，因为它可能在伐木营地工作过，因为它有90年的历史，因为它是我从古董店后地板上的真正残骸中修复出来的。所以有那种怀旧感。那种对古董横切锯的怀旧，
it's complicated. Because in it, I can't help but hear parallels to the way we think about wilderness. That nostalgia for the antique crosscut, it's complicated. Because in it, I can't help but hear parallels to the way we think about wilderness today. It makes me think back to something Adam told me, that one motivation behind protecting these places as wilderness was the desire to preserve a frontier frame of mind, that wilderness could be a place for the weary urban human to use traditional tools like the crosscut and imagine doing what their ancestors did on the open frontier.
很复杂。因为在其中，我不禁听到了与我们思考荒野方式的相似之处。那种对古董横切锯的怀旧，很复杂。因为在其中，我不禁听到了与我们今天思考荒野方式的相似之处。这让我想起亚当告诉我的事情，保护这些地方作为荒野背后的一个动机是渴望保留一种边疆心态，即荒野可以成为疲惫的城市人类使用横切锯等传统工具的地方，并想象做他们祖先在开放边疆所做的事情。
There's a certain romantic idea to using a vintage crosscut that feels really similar to the romance that Aldo Leopold and others felt about wilderness in the 19th century, the pursuit of something untouched, unsullied by contact with humans and industry. There seems to be this really big obsession with purity. This is Shandinez. Shandinez is a conservationist who used to lead crews within Sestrolands Conservation Corps, an all-indigenous environmental group based out of New Mexico. Weilding a crosscut has long been part of Shandin's family history.
使用老式横切锯有一种浪漫的想法，这感觉与奥尔多·利奥波德和其他人在19世纪对荒野感受到的浪漫非常相似，追求某种未受触动、未被人类和工业接触玷污的东西。似乎有一种对纯洁的巨大痴迷。这是尚迪内兹。尚迪内兹是一位环保主义者，曾领导塞斯特兰兹保护队，这是一个总部位于新墨西哥州的纯原住民环保组织。挥舞横切锯长期以来一直是尚迪家族历史的一部分。
Back in the mid-30s, both of her grandfather's were crosscut soyares for a logging company in the Chuska Mountains. Shandin never anticipated felling trees with cross cuts herself. But for the past 10 years, she's led trail crews into the back country on work trips, rarely going into the wilderness without a cross cut saw.
早在30年代中期，她的两位祖父都是丘斯卡山脉一家伐木公司的横切锯工。尚迪从未预料到自己会用横切锯砍树。但在过去的10年里，她带领步道工作组进入偏远地区进行工作旅行，很少在没有横切锯的情况下进入荒野。
And Shandine says she gets the romantic allure, both with cross cuts and with wilderness. I think before I became as involved with outdoor recreation and working on trails and increasing that access, I did have like this romanticized thought and I guess kind of like a colonized thought of like, wow, this is really beautiful. Humans are the worst. Keeping it in like this like quote, pristine state or before I realized that uninhabited land is a myth. Uninhabited land is a myth.
尚迪说她理解那种浪漫的诱惑，无论是对横切锯还是对荒野。我想在我参与户外休闲和步道工作并增加这种接触之前，我确实有这种浪漫化的想法，我想这是一种殖民化的想法，比如，哇，这真的很美。人类是最糟糕的。保持这种所谓的“原始”状态，或者在我意识到无人居住的土地是一个神话之前。无人居住的土地是一个神话。
But think about wilderness is that it never really existed. Not today, not in the days of Teddy Roosevelt or in the industrial revolution and definitely not back when European settlers landed in North America. revolution and definitely not back when European settlers landed in North America. Because long before these spaces were even referred to as wilderness, they were populated and tended to by the indigenous people who lived there. John Muir and Everett Russe came in and spoke about these places so eloquently, but it lacked a lot of knowledge. It lacked a lot and just holds a lot of deep-seated racism and hate towards Indians. John Meir, a forefather of the American wilderness movement, argued that wilderness should be cleared of all of its inhabitants and set aside to satisfy the urban humans need for spiritual renewal. In his writing, Mier described indigenous people as, quote,
但关于荒野的想法是，它从未真正存在过。不是今天，不是在西奥多·罗斯福时代，也不是在工业革命时期，更不是在欧洲定居者登陆北美时。因为在这些空间被称为荒野之前很久，它们就被居住在那里的原住民所居住和照料。约翰·缪尔和埃弗里特·鲁斯进来，如此雄辩地谈论这些地方，但它缺乏很多知识。它缺乏很多，并且对印第安人怀有许多根深蒂固的种族主义和仇恨。美国荒野运动的鼻祖约翰·缪尔主张，荒野应该清除所有居民，并留出来以满足城市人类对精神更新的需求。在他的著作中，缪尔将原住民描述为，引用：
dirty, lazy, and uncivilized. In one essay collection, he wrote to promote national parks. He assured perspective tourists that most indigenous people were dead or, quote, civilized into useless innocence. And remember, Ansel Adams, that famous nature photographer? Well, he actively avoided photographing any of the local Miwa who lived in Yosemite Valley, even though they were rarely out of his sight. He filled thousands of human-free negatives with land, he knew that the Miwa had tended
肮脏、懒惰和不文明。在一本为推广国家公园而写的散文集中，他向潜在的游客保证，大多数原住民已经死亡，或者引用，“被文明化为无用的天真”。还记得安塞尔·亚当斯，那位著名的自然摄影师吗？他积极避免拍摄任何住在优胜美地谷的当地米沃克人，尽管他们很少离开他的视线。他拍摄了数千张没有人类的底片，但他知道米沃克人已经照料了
to for at least 4,000 years. And he knew that indigenous people throughout the country were forcibly evicted from what are now our wilderness areas. All in the interest of protecting these spaces from human disturbance. But for me being of this land, you know, my people are of this land. It feels like a, I guess, like a continued exploitation of land and like the name of purity. And again, purity being like a staple of white supremacy and colonization. This pursuit of purity is a big part of what influenced the wilderness act of 1964,
至少4000年。他也知道全国各地的原住民被强行从现在我们的荒野地区驱逐。这一切都是为了保护这些空间免受人类干扰。但对我来说，作为这片土地的人，你知道，我的人民属于这片土地。这感觉像是一种，我想，对土地的持续剥削，以纯洁的名义。再一次，纯洁是白人至上主义和殖民主义的支柱。这种对纯洁的追求是影响1964年《荒野法案》的重要部分，
because coded within the language of preservation was that wilderness landscapes should be free from human presence. Ultimately, uninhabited wilderness as a concept had to first be created before it could be preserved. Despite its colonialist underpinnings, it's undeniable that the wilderness axe passage was a shining moment in American environmental history. It set millions of square miles of valuable land aside for the sake of protection from American capitalism. And in doing so, it said, we value what's already here. And yet, it's unclear whether the acts leave it be philosophy is still useful when it comes to land management.
因为在保护的语言中编码的是，荒野景观应该没有人类存在。最终，无人居住的荒野作为一个概念必须先被创造出来，然后才能被保护。尽管有殖民主义的基础，但不可否认的是，《荒野法案》的通过是美国环境史上一个闪耀的时刻。它为了保护免受美国资本主义的侵害，划出了数百万平方英里的宝贵土地。通过这样做，它说，我们重视已经存在的东西。然而，当涉及到土地管理时，该法案的“顺其自然”哲学是否仍然有用尚不清楚。
And some ecologists are pushing for a different approach. It's an approach that, more closely, echoes how wilderness land had been tended to by the indigenous people who lived there long before it was ever thought of as wilderness. Low intensity human intervention. Here's an example. Bandair National Monument in New Mexico is an area that's been ravaged by a century of fire suppression and livestock grazing, and it led to really damaging rates of soil erosion. Much of this land is in capital W wilderness, which means workers are limited to primitive tools. But in 2007, they made a bold decision. They decided to take chainsaws to nearly 5,000 acres of land.
一些生态学家正在推动一种不同的方法。这种方法更接近于在荒野被认为是荒野之前，居住在那里的原住民如何照料荒野土地。低强度的人为干预。这是一个例子。新墨西哥州的班德利尔国家纪念地是一个受到一个世纪的灭火和牲畜放牧蹂躏的地区，它导致了非常破坏性的土壤侵蚀率。这片土地的大部分属于大写W的荒野，这意味着工作人员仅限于使用原始工具。但在2007年，他们做出了一个大胆的决定。他们决定对近5000英亩的土地使用链锯。
Soyers cut small juniper trees and mulched the ground with their branches. This kind of action, using chain saws instead of crosscuts in the wilderness, and at such a scale, it was a rare exception to the wilderness-axe rule against motors. And it worked. In the 15 years since, rates of erosion have fallen by at least an order of magnitude, and the population of native grasses increased threefold. It's hard to imagine crosscut saws being able to wield such exponential results so quickly. Ultimately, these questions about wilderness, who and what it's for and how we relate
锯工砍伐了小杜松树，并用它们的树枝覆盖地面。这种行动，在荒野中使用链锯而不是横切锯，而且规模如此之大，是荒野法案禁止动力工具规则的一个罕见例外。而且它奏效了。在过去的15年里，侵蚀率下降了至少一个数量级，原生草的种群增加了三倍。很难想象横切锯能如此迅速地产生如此指数级的效果。最终，关于荒野的这些问题，它是为了谁和什么，以及我们如何与它相关联，
to it, it's a debate that will continue to rage on. Because at the heart of it all, wilderness doesn't mean the same thing to everyone, and it probably never will. Last summer, I hiked into the John Meer wilderness in the Sierra Nevada mountain range. At around 10,000 feet along a quiet trail, the sign at the wilderness boundary laid out the rules, simple enough to understand, closed to motor vehicles and motorized equipment, violations punishable.
这是一个将继续激烈的辩论。因为在这一切的核心，荒野对每个人来说意义并不相同，而且可能永远不会相同。去年夏天，我徒步进入了内华达山脉的约翰·缪尔荒野。在海拔约10000英尺的一条安静步道上，荒野边界的标志列出了规则，简单易懂，禁止机动车辆和动力设备，违者受罚。
It was August, too early yet for full sun, but the fog poured from the stony peaks beyond the tree line. I crossed the threshold into wilderness, suddenly very aware of how much effort went into creating an arbitrary border that I'd only recently begun to understand. As I plotted along, my eyes cast downward on the trail, I thought about all the sweat and precision that goes into carving trails like this out of mountainside, all the trees that were chopped with cross cuts to make a path like this possible.
那是八月，阳光还没完全出来，但雾气从树线之外的石峰中涌出。我跨过了进入荒野的门槛，突然意识到创造一个我最近才开始理解的任意边界需要付出多少努力。当我沿着步道走时，眼睛向下看着步道，我想到了将这样的步道从山腰上雕刻出来所付出的所有汗水和精确度，所有为了使这样的路径成为可能而用横切锯砍伐的树木。
The way we've romanticized our country's wilderness, I'm wary of it, but I'm also prone to it. I think about how easy it can be to fall into the idea that there are sacred lands, protected wilderness like this one, and perhaps more disposable lands, like the changing cities many of us return home to. I catch myself clinging to the romantic idea that when I step into the wilderness, I'm heading somewhere better than us, a place that's protected from us, that there are some places where we can still walk a dozen miles and not find a gas station or a McDonald's, but instead a glistening lake. Coming up, we learned that when the wilderness act stated that no machines are allowed in
我们浪漫化我们国家荒野的方式，我对此持谨慎态度，但我也很容易陷入其中。我想，陷入这样一种想法是多么容易：有神圣的土地，像这样的受保护荒野，也许还有更“一次性”的土地，比如我们许多人回到的不断变化的城市。我发现自己沉迷于一种浪漫的想法，即当我踏入荒野时，我正前往一个比我们更好的地方，一个免受我们侵害的地方，在某些地方我们仍然可以走十几英里而找不到加油站或麦当劳，而是找到一个波光粼粼的湖泊。接下来，我们了解到当《荒野法案》规定不允许机器进入
the wilderness, they really meant it. Stay tuned. And we're back with Lashmidon. Hey, Lasha. Hey, Roman. I love this episode so much. I love thinking about wilderness as kind of a designed space. Like, it's still something that's in the purview of the show, but it is almost completely the opposite of the show. Yeah. And, you know, in this episode, there were so many interesting rabbit holes that I wish I could have gone down as a reporter. You know, there's so much more to say when it comes to cross cuts, themselves, to conservation, which is our own can of worms, land management, Indigenous rights, land back. But I wanted to share just this one extra tiny tidbit with you that I ended up leaving
荒野时，他们是认真的。敬请期待。我们回来了，和拉什马·多恩在一起。嘿，拉什马。嘿，罗曼。我非常喜欢这一集。我喜欢把荒野看作一种设计空间。就像，它仍然是节目范围内的东西，但它几乎完全与节目相反。是的。而且，你知道，在这一集中，有太多有趣的“兔子洞”，作为一名记者，我希望我能深入挖掘。你知道，当涉及到横切锯本身、保护（这是我们自己的麻烦事）、土地管理、原住民权利、土地归还时，还有很多话要说。但我只想和你分享这一个额外的小花絮，我最终把它留在了
out of the episode, but I still find myself telling people at parties. Okay, I am ready. Go for it. So, do you remember some of that language that's used to describe what is and what isn't allowed in wilderness, according to the Wilderness Act? Yeah, I mean, the key things I remember are as no motorized objects, no mechanical transport, that kind of thing. Yes.
剧集之外，但我仍然发现自己在聚会上告诉人们。好的，我准备好了。开始吧。那么，你还记得用来描述根据《荒野法案》在荒野中允许和不允许什么的那些语言吗？是的，我的意思是，我记得的关键点是禁止机动物体、禁止机械运输之类的东西。是的。
And I find the language and choice of words in this piece of legislation really interesting, especially because the language kind of oscillates between the highly precise and poetically vague, sometimes even within the same paragraph. And there's these lyrical descriptions where wilderness is described using the words untrammeled
我发现这部立法中使用的语言和措辞非常有趣，尤其是因为这种语言在高度精确和诗意模糊之间摇摆不定，有时甚至在同一段落中也是如此。其中有一些抒情的描述，用“未受践踏”来形容荒野。
and primeval, you know, describing it as a place for a visitor who does not remain. And people are always referring back to this exact text, you know, this weirdly poetic document to try and sort out what is and isn't allowed in capital W wilderness. And one of the biggest debates has been about wheels. Whoa.
和“原始”，你知道，把它描述为一个“不留痕迹的访客”的去处。人们总是回头参考这段确切的文字，你知道，这份奇怪的诗意文件，试图理清在“荒野”（大写W）中什么是允许的，什么是不允许的。而最大的争论之一就是关于轮子。哇。
Okay. So, I mean, I know a wheel in axle is this sort of original, simple machine, but I would not have thought that would be banned. Yeah. Wheels are technically one of the simplest machines. And because of that, they're not allowed in the wilderness. Any kind of transportation with wheels, any tools with wheels, generally wilderness areas can only be accessed by horseback, backcountry skiing, kayaking or canoeing, hiking. I had no idea. The language says
好吧。我的意思是，我知道轮轴是一种原始的简单机械，但我没想到它会被禁止。是的，轮子在技术上是最简单的机械之一。正因如此，它们在荒野中是不被允许的。任何带有轮子的交通工具，任何带有轮子的工具，通常荒野地区只能通过骑马、野外滑雪、皮划艇或独木舟、徒步旅行进入。我完全不知道。法律条文说
no mechanized or motorized equipment shall be used. Mechanized means as in machine. We could have a whole podcast about Dalai's first unconcerned. Yeah, and Dalai says, back when the wilderness act first passed and there were these new rules to work with all of a sudden, trail crews would still use wheelbarrows to move material around. But then as managers began interpreting the wilderness act a little more strictly, they said, well, wait a minute, a wheelbarrow has a wheel, therefore it's mechanized equipment, and we shouldn't be using that in the wilderness. So the Forest Service, where Dolly worked, decided to stop using wheelbarrows and trail work
不得使用任何机械化或机动设备。机械化是指像机器一样。我们可以专门做一期关于达莉（Dali）最初的担忧的播客。是的，达莉说，当《荒野法案》刚通过，突然有了这些新规则要遵守时，步道工作人员仍然会使用独轮车来搬运材料。但后来，随着管理者开始更严格地解读《荒野法案》，他们说，等一下，独轮车有轮子，因此它是机械化设备，我们不应该在荒野中使用它。所以达莉工作的林务局决定停止在步道工作中使用独轮车
altogether, mostly to set an example for hikers and people coming into the wilderness recreationally. And their perspective was if land managers were seeing using wheelbarrows, what argument would there be to prevent other forms of wheeled transport on the same trails, like mountain bikes, baby strollers, and deer carts? Wow. Wait, what's a deer cart? I think it's a cart that's used to haul your game. Oh, I see. Okay, but how did they do their work without wheelbarrows? I mean, you know, second to a saw, it seems like the most important tool for a labor-intensive
完全停止，主要是为了给徒步旅行者和以娱乐方式进入荒野的人树立榜样。他们的观点是，如果土地管理者被看到使用独轮车，那么有什么理由阻止在同一条步道上使用其他形式的轮式交通工具，比如山地自行车、婴儿推车和猎物拖车呢？哇。等等，什么是猎物拖车？我想那是一种用来拖运猎物的推车。哦，我明白了。好吧，但他们没有独轮车怎么工作呢？我的意思是，你知道，除了锯子，这似乎是劳动密集型工作中最重要的工具
earth-moving job. Yeah, this is one of my favorite parts. So instead of wheelbarrows, they use shoulder bags, tote bags, basically. Sometimes known as dirt bags. To haul dirt and rocks from one place to another without using any form of machine, or even if it's simple machinery. It isn't just a delightful image. It is.
土方工程。是的，这是我最喜欢的部分之一。所以他们不用独轮车，而是用肩包，基本上就是手提袋。有时被称为“土袋”（dirt bags）。用来把泥土和岩石从一个地方搬到另一个地方，而不使用任何形式的机器，甚至简单的机械。这难道不是一个令人愉快的画面吗？确实是。
I mean, I've never had a positive connotation to the phrase dirt bag before, but now I do. It's just amazing. But it does seem very hard if you're just hauling dirt on your back. That seems incredibly difficult. It's incredible commitment. And today, there is one big exception to the No Wheels and Wilderness norm and its wheelchairs. In 1990, the Americans with Disabilities Act was able to negotiate with the Wilderness Act. So people who use wheelchairs for everyday indoor mobility are allowed to use them in a wilderness area. Oh, that makes sense. I'm glad they made that exception. But you mentioned mountain bikes, though. What about them? So in regards to mountain bikes, this is where things get a little bit spicy.
我的意思是，我以前从未对“土袋”（dirt bag）这个词有过积极的联想，但现在有了。这太神奇了。但如果你只是背着泥土搬运，这看起来非常辛苦。这看起来极其困难。这是一种令人难以置信的奉献精神。今天，关于“荒野中禁止轮子”的规定有一个重大例外，那就是轮椅。1990年，《美国残疾人法案》成功与《荒野法案》进行了协商。所以，日常室内活动使用轮椅的人被允许在荒野地区使用轮椅。哦，这很有道理。我很高兴他们做了这个例外。但你提到了山地自行车，它们呢？所以关于山地自行车，事情就变得有点棘手了。
Okay. Because mountain bikes, they aren't motorized. They are mechanized in that they provide a mechanical advantage with their wheels. And they are human powered. And they have a very large following. So their ambiguity kind of puts them in an awkward spot when it comes to wilderness access. Yeah, I bet, yeah. So several mountain biking groups have been pushing
好吧。因为山地自行车不是机动的。它们是机械化的，因为它们的轮子提供了机械优势。而且它们是人力驱动的。它们拥有非常庞大的追随者。所以它们的模糊性使它们在荒野准入方面处于一个尴尬的境地。是的，我敢肯定。所以几个山地自行车组织一直在推动
for decades, for mountain bikes to be allowed in the wilderness. And a big part of their argument takes us right back to that vague open-ended language in the wilderness act. People who say that mountain bikes shouldn't be considered mechanical transport say that the wilderness act could have explicitly banned bicycles in their language. They could have been specific, but they weren't. I mean, that's a good point, but the wilderness act was from 1964, right? And so, were mountain bikes even a thing then?
几十年来，一直推动山地自行车在荒野中被允许使用。他们论点的一个重要部分把我们带回了《荒野法案》中那些模糊、开放的措辞。那些认为山地自行车不应被视为机械运输工具的人说，《荒野法案》本可以在其措辞中明确禁止自行车。他们本可以写得很具体，但他们没有。我的意思是，这是一个很好的观点，但《荒野法案》是1964年的，对吧？那么，那时有山地自行车吗？
Mountain bikes weren't even invented at that point. Okay, okay. That's what I thought. Regular road bicycles were around and were used, but the first mountain bikes came around over a decade later. So some people say, you know, how could the writers of the Wilderness Act possibly have anticipated that people would have wanted to take their bikes into the wilderness, into the mountains. So their point of view is that the authors of the wilderness act never specifically intended to ban bikes and therefore bikes should be allowed in the wilderness.
那时甚至还没有发明山地自行车。好吧，好吧。我就是这么想的。普通的公路自行车当时已经存在并被使用，但第一批山地自行车是在十多年后才出现的。所以有些人说，你知道，《荒野法案》的起草者怎么可能预见到人们会想把自行车带进荒野，带进山里呢？所以他们的观点是，《荒野法案》的作者从未明确打算禁止自行车，因此自行车应该被允许进入荒野。
Exactly. And I will say this is only in regards to wilderness areas. You can use mountain bikes in state forests, state parks, national parks, things like that. But in regards to wilderness areas, another element to the argument that mountain bikers make is that they feel that they do less damage than hikers and equestrians who are both allowed on wilderness trails. And I mean, in 2006, the National Park Service released a study supporting that claim. The study was about what mode of travel affects trails the most.
没错。而且我要说，这仅限于荒野地区。你可以在国有林、州立公园、国家公园等地方使用山地自行车。但关于荒野地区，山地自行车爱好者论点的另一个要素是，他们认为自己比徒步旅行者和骑马者造成的破坏更小，而这两者在荒野步道上都是被允许的。我的意思是，2006年，国家公园管理局发布了一项支持这一主张的研究。该研究是关于哪种旅行方式对步道的影响最大。
And the results showed that horse trails led to the most severe levels of erosion, then hiking trails, and then bike trails, which showed very little signs of erosion. And on the other side of the debate, people argue that bicycles can damage habitat, disturb wildlife, still lead to some levels of erosion, and also that allowing bicycles in wilderness
结果显示，马道导致的侵蚀程度最严重，其次是徒步步道，而自行车道显示的侵蚀迹象很少。而在辩论的另一方，人们认为自行车会破坏栖息地、干扰野生动物、仍然会导致一定程度的侵蚀，而且允许自行车进入荒野
areas has the potential to increase conflict with hikers and limit the hikers ability to enter that dreamy wilderness mindset, you know, just kind of harshes the vibe. Yeah, I'm sympathetic to this because I'm much, I mean, I'm a hiker more than a biker, and bikes are very cool, but they totally harsh my vibe when I'm hiking. In any case, this debate about wheels and wilderness, it came into public conversation in a really big way in 2017, because that year there was an attempt to pass a bill literally called the Wheels Over Wilderness Bill. Okay. And this bill advocated for federal wilderness areas to allow not just mountain bikes, but all kinds of wheels. It didn't pass, but it did set anti-wheel advocates off.
地区有可能增加与徒步旅行者的冲突，并限制徒步旅行者进入那种梦幻般的荒野心态，你知道，这有点破坏氛围。是的，我很同情这一点，因为我更多的是一个徒步旅行者而不是骑行者，自行车很酷，但当我在徒步时，它们完全破坏了我的氛围。无论如何，关于轮子和荒野的这场辩论，在2017年以一种非常大的方式进入了公众视野，因为那一年有人试图通过一项名为“轮子越过荒野法案”（Wheels Over Wilderness Bill）的法案。好吧。这项法案主张联邦荒野地区不仅允许山地自行车，还允许各种轮子。它没有通过，但确实激怒了反轮子倡导者。
So I found dozens of fiery op-eds published in 2017 with headlines like, and I'm quoting my favorite one here, five lies being told to get mountain bikes into the wilderness. Okay. So yeah, it is getting spicy. It's a little contentious, yeah. And to each their own. For now though, all wheels,
所以我发现了2017年发表的几十篇激烈的评论文章，标题如——我在这里引用我最喜欢的一篇——“为了让山地自行车进入荒野而编造的五个谎言”。好吧。所以是的，它变得很棘手。确实有点争议。各有所好吧。不过目前，所有的轮子，
besides wheelchairs are still bent, and hikers and chill workers alike just navigate their way around that rule. And all this makes me think of this one hilarious anecdote that Dolly told me from her time working on trails and I just have to share it with you. Okay. So this one time when Dolly was leading a trail crew, her manager told her that there was a giant tire down in a wilderness area
除了轮椅，仍然是被禁止的，徒步旅行者和步道工作人员都在绕过那条规则。所有这些让我想起了达莉在步道工作期间告诉我的一个搞笑轶事，我必须和你分享。好吧。有一次，当达莉带领一个步道小组时，她的经理告诉她，荒野地区有一个巨大的轮胎
that had probably rolled down from the top of a ski hill. It was like the tire that went to a big loader machine or something. Sure enough, down in the creek bed was a six-foot diameter, huge rubber tire that probably weighed 300 pounds. And my boss said, can you get it out of the wilderness? So, Dolly tried to crowdsource for the best solution. And some people said, well, wait till the air quality boards says it's okay and burn it. I thought, gross. Other people were like, why don't you stretch the tire between two trees and then cut it into little pieces and haul it out? And I thought, my God, that would take forever. And then
它可能是从滑雪场顶部滚下来的。那就像是大型装载机之类的轮胎。果然，在河床里有一个直径六英尺、巨大的橡胶轮胎，可能重达300磅。我的老板说，你能把它从荒野里弄出来吗？所以，达莉试图众筹最好的解决方案。有些人说，好吧，等空气质量委员会说可以的时候把它烧了。我想，真恶心。另一些人说，为什么不把它拉在两棵树之间，然后把它切成小块运出来？我想，天哪，那要花很长时间。然后
one person said, well, get a big volunteer group for a boy scout troop and tip it on edge and roll it out. And somebody else said, no, that would be illegal. That would be using a wheel in the wilderness. I said, but it is a wheel in the wilderness. It was hilarious because they were saying it would be okay to carry it out, but not to roll it out because that would be using a wheel in the wilderness. And I said, that is just going too far with being a wilderness purist.
一个人说，好吧，找一个大的志愿者团体或童子军，把它立起来滚出去。另一个人说，不，那是非法的。那是在荒野中使用轮子。我说，但它本身就是一个在荒野里的轮子。这太搞笑了，因为他们说把它扛出去是可以的，但滚出去不行，因为那会被视为在荒野中使用轮子。我说，这在成为荒野纯粹主义者方面做得太过分了。
Oh my goodness. So what if they end up, they couldn't use it as a wheel. They couldn't use a wheel as a wheel. That is so funny to me. Okay, so what did she end up doing? Nothing. Nothing. I transferred to a different forest.
天哪。所以如果他们最终，他们不能把它当作轮子使用。他们不能把轮子当作轮子使用。这对我来说太搞笑了。好吧，那么她最后做了什么？什么也没做。我转到了另一个森林。
I don't know what happened. But if Dolly had her way, she said she probably would have buried it, which we all know, burying your problems isn't usually the best way to deal with them, but in this case, I get it. Wow, that is such an amazing story. Well, thank you so much, Lasha. It's so much fun.
我不知道发生了什么。但如果达莉有办法，她说她可能会把它埋了，我们都知道，埋掉你的问题通常不是处理它们的最好方法，但在这种情况下，我理解。哇，那真是一个令人惊叹的故事。好吧，非常感谢你，拉莎。这太有趣了。
Yeah, thank you. 99% Invisible was produced this week by La Shaman Dawn, edited by Kelly Prime, original music by Swan Riau, sound mix by Martin Gonzalez, fact checking by Sona Avakian. Delaney Hall is our senior editor, Kurt Colstad is our digital director, the Resident team includes Chris Barube, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Jason De Leon, Vivian Le, Jacob Moltenado Medina, Joe Rosenberg, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. The 99% of visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. Special thanks this week to Dolly Chapman, Adam Sowards, and Shundin Nez. Thanks also to Joe Sorrentino, Chaz Robles, Kyle Chujillo, and Robert Parks. 99% invisible as part of this titcher and serious XM podcast family, now headquartered six
是的，谢谢。本周的《99% Invisible》由La Shaman Dawn制作，Kelly Prime编辑，Swan Riau原创音乐，Martin Gonzalez混音，Sona Avakian事实核查。Delaney Hall是我们的高级编辑，Kurt Colstad是我们的数字总监，常驻团队包括Chris Barube、Emmett Fitzgerald、Christopher Johnson、Jason De Leon、Vivian Le、Jacob Moltenado Medina、Joe Rosenberg、Sophia Klatsker，以及我Roman Mars。99% Invisible的标志由Stefan Lawrence创作。本周特别感谢Dolly Chapman、Adam Sowards和Shundin Nez。也感谢Joe Sorrentino、Chaz Robles、Kyle Chujillo和Robert Parks。《99% Invisible》是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一部分，现在总部位于北边六个
blocks north in the Pandora building. And beautiful. Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI Oregon on Instagram, Reddit, and TikTok too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. And now when I meet someone who thinks I'm going to play the saw, you may have heard of people playing across the saw as a musical instrument. And I don't quite know how it's done. I think you need a bow like you'd play a violin and you bend it and that's something I still have to learn. I have no idea how to play music on a crosscut
街区，在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心的潘多拉大厦。而且很漂亮。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并参与讨论。你可以在Twitter上关注我@RomanMars，在Instagram、Reddit和TikTok上关注节目@99PI。你可以在99PI.org找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目的链接以及《99PI》的每一集往期节目。现在，当我遇到一个认为我会拉锯子的人时，你可能听说过人们把锯子当作乐器来演奏。我不太清楚它是怎么做到的。我想你需要一个像拉小提琴那样的弓，然后把它弯曲，这是我还需要学习的东西。我不知道怎么在横切锯上演奏音乐
saw. One, please, a violinist! They're on the banks of the Mosul, Marlene Sain. And then Marlene Sainte down took out a saw from a case and played it like a violin. It sounded exactly like this. Oh! you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
锯子。请，一位小提琴手！他们在摩泽尔河岸边，Marlene Sain。然后Marlene Sainte从盒子里拿出一把锯子，像拉小提琴一样拉了起来。听起来完全是这样的。哦！你 这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。